Harry asked Jaffe why did you call your
new book dream city number of reasons I
think that people often come to
Washington DC with some kind of a dream
in mind you know school kids come here
from cherry Oaks Ohio or wherever and
they might dream of becoming president
one day Congress people come here with
an idea about how they'd like to change
the world and our principal characters
were largely civil rights activists who
came to Washington DC after the civil
rights movement down south had come to a
close with the dream of making
Washington DC the first city run by
African Americans by government and
making it a place that was noteworthy
and made the dream of empowerment that
was begun down in the south true was
your favorite character in the book well
I won't lie Marion Barry is the favorite
character he's obviously the principal
character apart from the city itself
he's just an extraordinary person he has
made so much news nationally
internationally usually for the wrong
things unfortunately but he's a complex
person we found in researching his life
he's growing up in a family of other
informed sisters his getting involved
into the civil rights movement at the
same time he's also studying to have
chemistry degree at Fisk University
there all kinds of things about Marion
Barry that don't come through the
National international news that he was
the mayor caught smoking crack cocaine
other than Marion Barry here's another
person that you wrote about the dead
it's memorable well I would I would go
for a larrington who is the in a sense
the hero of the book he liked Marion
Barry the the son of a sharecropper
worked the field pulling tobacco in
North Carolina came to Washington DC
as part of a migration of African
Americans who came from the south to
Washington to seek their fortunes only
where where Marion Barry took a
political path which took him to two
places where he maybe didn't plan to go
al Arrington became a police officer
developed a stable relationship with his
wife worked his way up through the ranks
of the police department and wound up
being the african-american Metropolitan
Police Department sergeant who
investigated Marion Barry and was a
crucial I would say a key element in his
in the investigation that actually led
to the Vista set up and an arrest of
Marion Barry I think it's important to
note our Arrington goose' the officer
who had his hand on the doorknob as they
were prepared to burst into the Vista
hotel room to arrest Marion Barry in the
conflicts and Arrington to mine is a
black person going into arrest yet
another black person it's a high profile
sent to that case him the feelings he
had there we make for some was a
dramatic moment exactly we we asked our
Arrington how he felt when he when he
reached Marion Barry he was the first
police officer to reach Marion Barry and
I said how did it feel he said it was
like a knife in the heart because while
he'd been hunting this man for a full
year when he got him he realized that
this is this is my brother and and he
had terrible conflict that I think a lot
of african-americans feel in general
about you know their own brothers how
they deal with a white society and that
those are some of the things that we try
to bring out in dream city what do you
do for a living full-time I'm a
political reporter for WRC TV channel 4
here in Washington the NBC own station
here in the district and that's what I
do full-time not too much time how long
have you done that I've been doing it
since 1989 I used to work for the
Washington Post covering local politics
Marion Barry and Chuck Robb in the
Virginia but in 1989 the TV station
Barry was it was still then the mayor
and the station wanted someone they
thought could
report on the city and reports
specifically on Marion Barry
so they waived some additional dollars
in my face and said come try TV Tom stop
being that newspaper journalist and now
I did it's been fun for five years what
year did you come to Washington I've
moved here in 1970 for our work for John
W Davis a member of Congress who was
defeated that year by Larry McDonald and
so I needed a job and I've got a job at
the Washington Post as a desk editor in
1974 where his Homer is Atlanta Georgia
I must say though I was in Washington in
1968 and 69 and as a Navy reservist at
the Washington Navy Yard which was my
first real introduction to the local
Washington but I'm from Atlanta Larry
McDonald was the congressman went down
on ka L dubba like the John Birch
Society member from North Java from the
congressional district right outside of
Atlanta what was John Davis's politics
former judge twelve moderate North
Georgia congressman twelve years had a
drinking problem and it got increasingly
distant from his district and came got
aloof in Washington and got defeated
Harry Jeffrey what do you do full-time I
am a national editor at Washingtonians
magazine and I write about local
politics local business whatever comes
up columns longer articles were you from
originally
Philadelphia where'd you go school I
went to school of public schools in
Philadelphia and then I went to college
Dickinson College in Pennsylvania
and when did you first come to
Washington well like Tom I came to work
for somebody on Capitol Hill I came in
1978 to work for Patrick Leahy as his
press secretary however I was here in
1971 to protest the Vietnam War where I
was first arrested at Dupont Circle
first you make some news here do you
both live in the district yes I live in
the district with my wife and three
children I have two daughters who are in
the public school public elementary
school so yeah I think that for Tom and
I having a stake in the District of
Columbia
was part of our motivation for writing
this book I think that while the book is
you know may seem critical there's a
tremendous amount of affection that Tom
and I share for that for the city we'll
marionberry be the next mayor of
Washington DC barring an extraordinary
event which I can't scope out in my mind
Marion Barry should be Republican Carol
Schwartz in November and a couple of
lesser-known
independent candidates who will also be
on the ballot but his primary win with
47% of the vote was extraordinary many
people expected him to have a very good
chance of winning but no one only one
person out of the entire city predicted
Barry would get that high of a vote how
did he do it well he did it I think two
two ways in particular he he exploited
what is a tremendous amount of anger and
defiance across the board and the black
community that we write about and try to
explain and get to the roots of in dream
city secondly his plea as a on religious
grounds that he was a redeemed
individual that he had seen the bottom
and worked his way back up has a
tremendous appeal to African Americans
and thirdly and I think most importantly
Marion Barry is a masterful politician
he knows how to get people to the polls
to vote for him and the mechanics of
that which is something that as we point
out in dream city he learned in snick
the Student Nonviolent Coordinating
Committee in the deep south during the
civil rights movement he has brought all
of those tactics and all those talents
to bear in in every one of his campaigns
so he brought people to the polls and he
brought people to the polls who hadn't
voted before which is one of the things
that I think he deserves quite a lot of
credit for he registered as many as
12,000 new voters or had some role in
registering that many new voters he also
appealed to the middle class black
Washingtonians who know that the city
government is wasting too much money
it's going to have to be cut either by
the city officials
by Congress and so in looking to someone
to cut the city budget with we're
talking about community were often
talking about their jobs and their
contracts with city government who would
you best trust to cut the government
someone who has denounced the government
or someone who perhaps built it and
knows it best and knows that he must
make cuts will make cuts that will do
about doing his best to protect them in
their jobs those are practical politics
Tip O'Neill once said you know all
politics is local and the fact is that's
true here in Washington for all the
people who only know Marion Barry
through the nasty headlines and the
videotape of the crack cocaine Anson
don't know the extraordinary work he did
in this in Washington to open up the
doors of government to the black people
of Washington who were shut out for
years decades then people remember that
give us a profile of Washington DC how
many people live here what's the racial
makeup of the community and where's the
power and how much does it cost to make
this city work well let me begin by
saying that we've got fewer than 600,000
residents which is a plummeting number
of inhabitants at its height the city
had 800,000 people and that was I think
in the 50s so there's been a steady
drain of people this city is is divided
I think by two waterways primarily the
Anacostia River which is a tributary of
the Potomac separates the the poorer
black population from the rest of the
city and there's often a saying of
across the tracks or across the river
across the tracks in southern town in
Washington DC across the rivers across
the Anacostia then there is the Rock
Creek Rock Creek itself and Rock Creek
Park the wealthier white population
lives west of the park and in the in the
center of the city and in in
neighborhoods all across that the great
area between the park and Anacostia
River is a thriving black middle-class
fine churches
good schools people that just want their
piece of the American Dream they just
want to live well send their kids to
college and follow the the pathway that
a lot of black middle-class people have
followed in the city where's the money
come from to operate the community and
how much local power do they have well a
lot of the money comes from the very
people who live here and work here it's
commonly believed that the city is
simply a ward of the federal government
that's not true via budgets three point
seven billion dollars a year three point
seven billion most of that money is
raised through local businesses and
local tax payers individuals like Harry
and I that's where the money comes from
we have a thriving business community
here the downtown Washington was rebuilt
in the 1980s they pay a great deal in
taxes many people say they don't pay
enough taxes but that's where the money
comes from and the power
unfortunately belongs to Congress under
the Constitution the current the
Congress has full authority over at the
District of Columbia and only since 1974
has there been any kind of local Home
Rule government and then elected mayor
and city council to run the day-to-day
affairs of the city but everything is
subject to disapproval by the Congress
it doesn't matter whether you're for or
against abortion Congress and the
president have stopped abortions in this
city and if they don't like the color of
taxi cabs they can also change that so
everything life in death matters
Congress controls second to that is the
what essentially white business
community that much of which is located
outside of the city now also controls a
great deal of the economic wealth of the
city although there are substantially
wealthy people black people in
Washington the power generally resides
in Congress the white business community
and then the people who have limited
powers to affect their local government
whose Jeff Cohen Jeff Cohen is a local
Washingtonians aged here went to school
here the friend in Marion Barry early on
saw Marion Barry as a politician who he
could relate to and became a
I guess Godfather to to marionberries
son vacation with Marion Barry and
Nantucket and use those contacts for his
own self-aggrandizement he's a developer
who would use the city government as
kind of a banker of last resort to
guarantee loans that made him wealthy at
the end of the Barry first Barry regime
Jeff Cohen no went bankrupt and that's
in no small part because he lost his
patron Marion Barry shows a fundamental
conflict where a businessman will take
advantage of his his dealings with the
city government you say that when he
filed for bankruptcy he had liabilities
of fifty four million dollars and assets
of one hundred and twelve thousand
dollars but yet right after filing
bankruptcy he was found to still have
his home and this Sidwell Friends
schools and going to the White House or
someplace with Bill Clinton who can you
explain that well I would say that the
the bankruptcy in in this country is a
as a way to get people a second chance
he he did have to to pay off some of his
loans but his father is a wealthy man
and I think that he used those kinds of
ties to continue living pretty much the
lifestyle that he he was living when he
was when he was on a high and it's true
that the rich go through bankruptcy far
different than people of modest or more
normal means on there are ways that with
lawyers and others to get to have
bankruptcy but still take vacations to
Alaska but I think the relationship with
Jeffrey Cohen with Marion Barry
demonstrates another aspect we try to
point out in dream city is that for all
the rhetoric about anti-white business
establishment not hiring black people
that Marion Barry was is and was and is
quite comfortable in the Suites of
Washington talking to the powers the
white power structure one of his stated
goals in this campaign and others on the
positive side has been that he is a
person who's able to talk to the poorest
of the poor and the richest of the rich
a cynic might turn that around and say
that he that he scams the poor and
cuddles the rich certainly there are
problems in the city in terms of not new
taxes but collecting some of the taxes
that are owed from this major business
community and some people believe that
Perry has been so close to that
community that the boards and
commissions that should be collecting
those taxes don't because of Barry's
influence with them whose ivanhoe
Donelson Ivanhoe Donaldson a true star
and leading light of the Student
Nonviolent Coordinating Committee one of
the most brilliant political strategists
to come out of the southern civil rights
movement son of a New York police
officer came to Washington
shortly after Marion Barry did and
became marionberries alter ego his
principal political adviser engineered
his first political victories in both in
City Council and his first mayoral
victory
unfortunately for various reasons some
of which we try to reach into some of
which are hard to divine Ivanhoe
Donaldson got into debt when he was a
head of the Department of Employment
Security one of the top jobs in the
Barry administration and he began to
embezzle money he was caught and he
admitted to embezzling one hundred and
ninety thousand dollars from the city
government and served time in jail for
that and it was a tremendous blow to
Barry because it happened in 86 when
Barry was starting to slide down the
path that would lead him to to personal
dissipation
losing Ivanhoe Donaldson as a rudder at
that point was crucial you asked who was
my favorite character will Ivanhoe is
the saddest character for all the
reasons Harry just stated he worked for
the Department of Employment Services
the job for that agency of course is to
get jobs for the people in the city
unemployment in the african-american
community hovers from males were close
to 50% on a regular basis the concept
that
a fixture of the Civil Rights Movement
like Ivanhoe had been corrupted and in
the process of trying to govern I was
just really sad in many ways Ivanhoe
took money and and sponsored parties for
orphans and did all kinds of good things
but he also started driving Mercedes and
owning an expensive condominium and
buying credit-card bills for a dinner at
Washington's expensive restaurant so he
lost his bearings much like Marion Barry
did Ivanhoe went to jail for three years
and he's been back in town working as a
consultant trying to help Marion Barry
and others and so he's also a tragic
figure in this dream city right now I
hope they're looking right maybe a
future chapter that he's turned himself
around
he's married Treadwell Harry Treadwell
strong woman brilliant woman marion
barry's second wife
why is he had this he's on his fourth
marriage right now he was briefly
married when he was in school down in
Tennessee and Mary Treadwell his second
marriage crucial in the early years of
marion barry's political life here in
Washington in developing pride Inc which
was a self-help political job bank that
operated back in the in the late 60s and
again a sad story to be told here as
Ivanhoe did Mary became a little bit
more involved in the in the trappings of
the of the organization she was running
wound up driving a Jaguar and living in
the Watergate Hotel and she was also
found herself on the wrong end of a of a
lawsuit was was charged with embezzling
money I don't think she was ever correct
me if I'm wrong she was not ever found
guilty of that it was a lesser charge
and just for this very moment I can't
remember but it's much lesser charge and
what she had been accused of but she is
another so another fallen figure who had
to serve time you you though have some
scenes that you described in the book
and language in quote marks of what
Marion Barry was out allegedly
philandering with other women would came
home one night and you have married
Treadwell putting a gun to his head
pillow as he hit as his head hit the
pillow
and and the dressing there was a strong
language he should be doing that anymore
that she would like to take care of the
situation yes we do have that language
in the book it's a words I mad at that
but we we've got that from information
from contemporaneous people who were
aware of what happened who she spoke to
and we also told her we were reporting
it and did did you speak to her about
the book yes before that we told you yes
we interviewed Harry interviewed
extensively but also went to her and
told her what we were publishing
how'd you divide your responsibilities
in the book who ever had the time I'll
answer that because Harry Harry's name
is on the book first and that's an
appropriate place because he was the
driving force he's the person who called
after the arrest of Marion Barry in 1991
we weren't he didn't really know each
other except being in the same city and
said you know the city and this man is a
hell of a book and let's do it and but
as a magazine writer more focused on
long-term projects Harry was in position
to spearhead the research and gathered
we worked in his attic and it's a
television reporter more attuned to the
day-to-day types of things that are
going on it was a combination that we
did I had a lot of research from my
years of a decade of covering Marion
Barry in the city a lot of files left
over from my days at the Washington Post
it's all that went into dream city but
Harry was the driving force to get the
book done and we decided he would write
in his voice and that would be the
editor of it so we wouldn't be writing
two different books and then trying to
smash them together like books often do
I think people say about dream city that
it reads very well whatever the
criticisms are it reads very well I
think that's because we chose to let
Harry write the book with my input is
that right Harry well you were so kind
to me Tom and I when my agent came to me
and said this is a this is a book that
will do well and I can find someone to a
publisher in this case Simon and
Schuster
to to go ahead and publish the book I
frankly didn't think I had enough
reporting experience and didn't know the
characters and didn't know the story as
well as the Tom Sherwood who was then
and still is the the principal Dean of
Washington reporters when it comes to to
local politics I mean Tom's a guy who
knows Marion Barry I think they have a
relationship if I'm not mistaken that
kind of goes beyond hey I'm a reporter
and he's a politician there's an
understanding there that I I never could
attain so I worked well with Tom as a as
the as per providing me with the kind of
material and grist and detail that I
needed would Marion Barry talked to you
for the book no he didn't talk
officially for the book of course he had
talked for a decade so I told him he
said no he wrote him letters and said
would please talk to us and he wouldn't
talk to us and he said what's in it for
me and that's what the fact is we know
all the bad stuff I want to talk to you
about the good stuff well it turned out
we didn't know all the bad stuff there's
a surprised us but he didn't want to do
it and even now he doesn't really would
like to talk about the book he doesn't
dispute the book he doesn't he just says
that we're I'm a better reporter than I
am a writer I don't know what that means
it's just way he just kind of dismisses
it he says look the book happened all
these things happen in the past
I'm the new person I'm a new Marion
Barry I acknowledged my problems with
women with drugs with my kids taking my
hand off the tiller for the government
and I'm moving on and so he doesn't want
to address the book in that reason but I
wish he had talked to us it would have
been a better book who else did not talk
to your would not agree to talk to you
well surprisingly enough
very few people after Barry talked to
you if he would not Rufus cafe Fe Barry
marionberries third wife who he married
just before running for mayor in 1978
and who's you know fathered I'm sorry
mother his first his only child
Christopher who stuck with him all
during his travails and during his very
public demise in
in court came to court every single day
and sat there and had to you know pain
stricken listen to the testimony of
marion barry's various paramours i sat
behind fe berry for many of those court
dates she decided not to speak to us and
and i think i you know i try to think
why she didn't i think that she also
wanted to leave the the episode behind
her and left town shortly after after so
she we tried to find out more about her
we the median biographical material in
there about her but she's moved to to
hampton virginia where she's been
teaching at the hampton university there
she had planned to write her own books
he talked about writing her own book she
was portrayed pretty much as the
long-suffering wife under Mary berry
although friends said that she too had
her own active lifestyle and they lived
apart once even admitted that maybe in
all the times that they had been married
from 1978 until 1991 or whatever it was
that they maybe it had dinner six times
together because they led separate lives
there was an arrangement which one
friend of Effie Barry said she was
strong enough to stay but too weak to
leave was Karen Johnson
let's see Karen Johnson one of the
earliest lovers of Marion Barry to kind
of make it into the public spotlight
because there was a an allegation that
she supplied Marion Barry with with
cocaine and she this this is this is if
marion barry's first term began in 1979
two years later he began his
relationship with with Karen Johnson
she served time in jail and that episode
was I think the first crack in in marion
barry's public facade that linked him
with another woman and and drugs how did
he meet her and a nightclub here in town
as mayor Beavis mayor Marion Barry had a
notorious reputation as a womanizer do
you hate that word this is a terrible
court but and but he was even when he
was on the school board people who
worked there at the time said you know
he as a school board president he would
walk out into the into the audience and
and ask people if they're single or not
and where do they live and what's your
phone number and then got a business
number then say no I mean your home
number
I mean was just unabashed about it Karen
Johnson again the only because of the
drug connection with her her boyfriend
who alleged was alleged to have provided
the cocaine for Marion Barry did that
become public at all how did is a
relationship with her work you've got
quite a bit in there of how you know he
would go to her beau at night he was a
nocturnal visit to me he was very called
himself a night owl after a lot of
publicity about his activities which
very simply would would have his
limousine drive to him to her apartment
moves just as we found out one of many
apartments he visited over time the
various women around in the end what did
she did she testify against him
no she never did and there was jail
there where she went to jail and there
were allegations and some quite explicit
information that pinned payments to
Karen Johnson by marionberries friends
losses rumors and business friends
people who actually delivered cash to
her in order to buy her silence and for
whatever reason it did buy her silence
you name those friends yes we do who are
they see John Clyburn and Roy little
John yeah where do you get those kind of
names
well they acknowledge giving money to
her they said it wasn't vague knowledge
giving the money to Karen Johnson but
they didn't say they said it wasn't for
any payoff and no one could prove they
were payoffs Karen Johnson would refuse
to testify she went to jail I've
forgotten how many months he stayed in
jail she had a small son the prosecutors
thought that it's a center to jail
perhaps being separated from her son
would make her testifies she chose not
to and to this day she has never told
her side of the story she's had some
conversations but
with one TV interview but she's really
never told the whole story and of course
Marion Barry hasn't either he's Charles
Louis Charles Lewis
son of a very wealthy Virgin Islands
family who had difficulty with drugs of
his own before he met Marion Barry came
to Washington DC worked in the city
government met Marion Barry in the
mid-1980s and then when when Barry
started to kind of go downhill he would
often go to the islands for
entertainment and one of the first times
that he went down to the Virgin Islands
with rashida Moore who was the the
paramour who actually led to his
downfall it was with Charles Lewis on a
boat where they is according to
testimony by both of those folks there
was a quite a bit of drugs in marijuana
and cocaine consumed on the boat in the
Virgin Islands with Charles Lewis and an
Rasheeda more present at the time
Charles Lewis became a principal accuser
of Marion Barry in court testimony I
think it's important to know that
Charles Lewis had been here in the 70s
then went back to the islands but then
was currying something we don't we
cannot say it was drugs but I had a lot
of murky jobs let's just call it that
but he was a catalyst that really
started the specific downfall of Marion
Barry because in in the 1988 in December
of 1988 that's when Marion Barry which
was the Ramada Inn here in Washington
downtown to visit Chuck Lewis as it
turned out was in fact to get drugs at
the time Barry's that was just somebody
he knew and that Chuck Lewis was down
and out needed the job and try to give
all these various explanations but it
was clear at that time that something
was up and that prompted the prosecutor
Jay Stevens to pretty much reopen an
investigation into marionberries
activities and they pursued both chuckle
ooh and buried at the same time when was
the decision made by Jay Stevens the
former US Attorney in the district to
pursue Mary what was a date well
interestingly enough
just going back a little bit Chhotu
Geneva who preceded J Stevens had a
number of investigations that were
terminated by Jay Stevens when Jay
Stevens got into office he said you
haven't gotten the guy why don't you
just drop everything I think was
important to know Jay Stevens is a white
conservative Republican former White
House aide who was appointed by Reagan
Reagan by Reagan right and when the
Ramada Inn episode came about which
means that when it became clear that
Marion Barry had visited Chuck Lewis and
that there was cocaine in the room and
the Chuck Lewis had apparently tried to
give some cocaine to one of the chamber
maids at the Ramada Inn when that
happened there were police officers
involved there was enough going on that
and a larrington became involved
he's the MPD saw a police sergeant who
got involved there was enough at that
point and that would have been December
1988 right but there was late December
so the decision actually to do a
full-scale investigation came only after
the DC Police Department stars they had
been under the thumb of Marion Barry
height forward and then chief Turner
refused to try to cover up the sensitive
it's just too messy and the police
chief's the police chief in this
principal assistant Ike forward pretty
much wash their hands that we're not
getting involved with this and as the
the within the coming weeks at the
January of 89 is really when the
decision was made to do a full
investigation of this grand jury
investigation how many times was Marion
Barry been elected mayor of the city of
Washington so far three times I'd say
three and a half because he's so close
to being elected the fourth time which
is an interesting point that few
Americans really quite understand is
that is that how young the local
political system is here Marion Barry
when he was elected his first three
times was only the second mayor to be
elected look you know by the by the
citizenry of Washington DC since the
1800s who was the first
dr. Washington in 1974 when Congress
passed home rule for the city in 1973
and Walter Washington who had been a
first day appointed mayor by Lyndon
Johnson in the 60s ran and won the first
term as an elected mayor and then grant
again in 1978 but lost out to Barry in a
3-way race that's remarkably similar in
many respects to the race we just had
but now Walter Washington is retired so
then the city has had in effect as
mayors Walter Washington Marion Barry
sharon pratt kelly and if Marion Barry
is elected again in 20 years it will
have had three mayor's and Marion Barry
for most of that time what happened
sharon pratt dixon Kelly she was as well
politically she was a disaster she used
to say that she was and she's still in
office until January 2nd 1995 she would
say that I'm not a politician like she
came out of them she was a hometown
Washingtonians who had worked as a
lawyer and was worked for the Pepa for
the Power Company and she ran on a
reformed platform in 1990 as sharon
fried dixon saying that she would fix
all the problems that marion barry had
created this she was embarrassed for
home her hometown that she was not a
politician but she was a politician she
just turned out to be a bad one and so
many different levels she had been the
national treasure of the Democratic
National Committee she had been a member
of the Democratic National Committee as
the National Committee woman from
Washington since 1977 in 1982 she had
run the mayoral campaign of Patricia
Roberts Harris another hometown
Washingtonians with a national
reputation who failed to unseat Barry
so Kelly mayor Dixon was in fact
involved in the city but she turned she
had a tremendous victory upset victory
1990 against some city council
candidates and in the world lay at her
feet but rather than embracing the
various elements had opposed her she
fought with him and she ended up
fighting with the Congress the courts
the media the city council and in the
business community she it was either her
way or the highway in so many cases that
people said
get it we can't work with you and while
she did some things as a reformer her
personality and her politics isolated
her to the extent that she was there
even the Washington Post which endorsed
her in 1990 didn't do it this time
population is five hundred and eighty
thousand something like that but how
many what percentage are
african-americans seventy percent just
under seventy percent
there's about I'd say 2 or 3 percent
Hispanic Asian and Asian over a person a
day is killed you say at some point
you're booked at a young black man is
killed once a day why well primarily the
drug trade primarily the lack of
opportunity the lack of perceived
opportunity you know one of the one of
the events that we described is when
George Bush who was the starting at
another war on drugs wanted an example
to go on national TV and talk about and
so he arranged for the DEA to set up the
Drug Enforcement Square which is right
across from the White House then indeed
it happened the African American from
Washington DC who was set up had to be
given directions to the White House he
lived in a neighborhood maybe as the
crow flies a mile or two away didn't
know how to get there there so there's a
part of Washington that is so enclosed
and divorced from the rest of the city
that the drug culture the drug life and
the lack of respect for human for for
life can become that vicious where are
the murders committed most of the
murders are committed in South East and
in parts of Northeast Washington rarely
in this city unlike Miami and other
tourist towns tourism being arts number
two industry here do we have reports of
tourists being attacked and shot with I
think one tourists in ten years maybe
has been shot and killed
that was one person an elderly gentleman
who had strayed away from downtown and
any regular parts that tourists might go
to
I know we have a terrible problem with
guns in the city we had the strongest
anti-gun law in America there no one can
own a handgun if you didn't have it
before 1977 but the borders are poorest
of Virginia and Maryland a lot of the
guns in fact come from Virginia another
thing with this city does not have the
established territorial gains that some
urban areas have and so there are a lot
of fights in the drug community over
who's going to control what what drug
trafficking there is and some of the
poor neighborhoods and those are
constantly people being killed where did
the whites live in the community almost
entirely west of Rock Creek Park in the
northwest quadrant of the city and I'd
say probably 90% of the white population
lives in that particular area Ward 3
some in war 2 which is Georgetown on
Capitol Hill how many murders committed
in Ward 3 I'd say maybe one or two
that's about it sometimes none in a full
year you're two or three at most and
they've been sensational crimes an
armored guard security guard being shot
at a restaurant that type of thing
what's so attractive about crack cocaine
it's cheap makes you feel it let me take
this go court it would be what's like
it's cheap makes you feel great and and
it's highly addictive that if you are
that you if you first try it one or two
times and that I'm told to high such
that you just cannot believe that you
can do anything else but get that high
again that mothers have been known to
they're obviously to leave their
children and in four children and go out
in search of crack cocaine having sex in
exchange not for money but for crack
cocaine it is quite powerful how much is
it I think you can get it from five
dollars a yeah I mean it's you can get
it comes in a little tiny plastic
containers you can get it from us as
much as little as five or ten dollars
there's one thing about the murder rate
that I think is important to point out
is that you know my personal criticism
of Marion Barry is not so much his
personal failings but his failure as a
mayor and in his last six years
especially he allowed the pub
housing projects to deteriorate to to
the point where Washington DC's public
housing what became the worst in the
entire nation which is a breeding ground
for crime for health problems for
everything secondly under his watch the
the police department was was very much
crippled because of lack of funds
because of cronyism because of the poor
technology so the the marriage or the
convergence of those two aspects of
Barry's government public housing into
into deterioration the police not
prepared to handle the influx of crime
is what contributed to the murder rate
how long did Marion Barry spend in jail
six months where did he go he briefly
was at Petersburg Virginia and then
there was an alleged incident there of a
sexual misconduct with a female visitor
what does that mean well it means that
the it was alleged by another inmate
that while Marion Barry was in the
visiting room with a female visitor that
the female visitor performed oral sex on
him but you say in the book that the
person that did the alleging was a white
inmate right that wasn't yet another
when this dream City points out again
and again that nothing is seen through
just clear eyes of race and race racial
fears and racism plays a role in
virtually everything and again this was
an allegation that the inmate that was
made these allegations against Barry was
white had worked in the in the warden's
office and didn't like Barry and then it
and but it was enough was found that the
prison system the federal prison system
did in fact move Barry to a place in
Pennsylvania that was say in researching
that very incident that had a direct
conversation with the alert an inmate
who alleged the incident he never
specifically saw what he said he saw
it's just that it looked like something
was happening he never specifically saw
the actual act who's Jim sleeper Jim
sleeper is a columnist for Newsday right
now he wrote a book called the closest
of strangers which is about the
relationship between liberal why
and blacks in New York City let me read
you know this course is on the back
jacket it says and he's writing about
your book he says a vivid account of how
the complex legacies of white racism and
white guilt commingled with the deep
hurt and mistrust at the center of black
politics to let one man Marion Barry
preempt the development of an integrated
civic culture in our nation's capital
what does that mean it's a mouthful take
it in part well I I think that it that
he makes a number of good points that we
try to develop a dream city first of all
there is the tremendous miss mistrust
and distrust of the white establishment
is it the root of politics here Congress
is a you know in fact runs the city or
has the power to run the city this is a
white establishment organization by and
large the second thing that I think is
important here is that politics in
Washington DC are so young and so
fragile and marionberries expertise as a
political operator allowed him to
commandeer control of the Democratic
Party which has ten to one advantage
over the Republican Party to control the
City Council which which was called
marionettes during his his tenure as
mayor and to basically boy you know kind
of put down any attempt to develop a
political counterpoint to his own
control the fact is the white racism who
speaks of is that there was the home
rule for the city limited home rule and
it was reluctantly given by Congress in
fact the Congress was just uh this is
distracted by Watergate in other matters
and but many black people rightly feel
and know that if white people could they
would take the city back and not allow
black people to run and that is heard
not on public television programs like
this but you can hear that remark as you
go around the country in the city
in fact I was in Florida this past week
and someone wrote in say well those
people have elected Marion Barry they
should have the home rule should be
taken away and Congress should run the
city again and I think that's one of the
things that people don't quite
understand the people of Washington
African Americans who live here and many
whites of goodwill resent a very much
the the external forces of the country
always talk about those people in
Washington as if they're somehow
subhuman and I think race does play a
major factor there in that and so when
some African Americans have voted for
Marion Barry this time said look here's
an in-your-face vote you think you were
you're worried about Marion Barry and he
shouldn't be our mayor we're sick of you
telling us who were gonna vote for I'm
gonna vote for Marion Barry and this I
think it'll do a good job I'm gonna vote
just cause you hate him so and that's a
racial insecurity that's not the best
reason to vote for mayor but that's a
legitimate reason and I can understand
that I got that feeling throughout the
city back to Rasheeda Moore and Al
Arrington did you interview Rasheeda
more for this book we attempted to by
the time that we made that attempt she
was in the witness protection program
long gone from Washington what does that
mean it means that after she testified
against Marion Barry in in federal court
she was essentially given a new identity
a new home by the US Marshals and the
FBI because they considered her life to
be in danger if she stayed in Washington
DC go back to the beginning of the
investigation you mentioned earlier
about Jay Stevens going after Marion
Barry after the Ramada and incident how
did they find Rasheeda more the meaning
the the FBI Rasheeda more of course
being the beautiful model that Barry had
met previously and carried on a
relationship with that's part of the
aisle
Arrington story is is the it's the
unraveling of connections Charles Lewis
had a had an address book that had lots
of names and I think there was an R
scene there or something
which was repeated Morris nickname and
it was I think I'll go through all the
steps because it's quite complicated but
out of the book and in dream too anyhow
they finally discovered that Rashida
Moore is the daughter of a local
Washington woman who is the organist in
the local church and they attempt to
talk to her and they're going to but
then it all falls apart
and they bring her in through classic
interrogation techniques to talk to her
and she doesn't want to say anything and
then she and she leaves but then
ultimately she's arrested on a small
charge out in Los Angeles I think of
driving charge or something like that
and they're able to persuade her to talk
you know again what's the year where
this investigation starts it starts in
January of 89 Rashida Moore was not
actually brought in to testify until
Christmas okay at some point point out
in your book that she was down and out
and on food stamps and Welfare and she
had children and where were they they
were in Los Angeles and there was a
problem with her with her with the
children were staying I think for a
while with the father or the children I
don't miss remember this on national
television so I'm gonna be careful about
that but they were I think was a driving
charge in which they arrested her and
they said they had found her they were
not to talk to her in a larrington the
Bible I had an impact in this and you
keep bringing up his relationship to the
Bible in his use of it explain that and
again a larrington is a Washington DC
police demands yes al had a near fatal
traffic accident in the in the mid 80s
and it became a very religious
experience for him because they the a
minister was called to the hospital to
administer last rites the doctors
thought he was finished he recovered and
it became a religious awakening for him
he when he was interrogating a number of
the people who were close friends of
Marion Barry or who would and who would
you would expect to be protecting Marion
Barry he would read passages in the
Bible that appealed to them essentially
to a higher God than the
Oh God that marionberry had become and
it worked in enough cases and it worked
with with Charles Lewis and he also
would he would hear this technique of
drawing fish little fish had a big fish
up here and then we draw a little fish
down here and he would talk to various
people and say now you're down here
you're one of these little fish we're
going to he would draw a line towards
the big fish he said we're not worried
about these little fish were going
towards the big fish and invite any
official get in our way you know we're
gonna have to deal with you know
something we want to know what it is
because we don't want you we want to fix
this so in addition to the religious
aspects we had people and tears and the
interrogation rooms with his ability to
call on the the deep religious culture
of an African American community in
addition to that was a cold steel of the
cop saying here's what we're doing and
don't you forget it
where is al Arrington today al Arrington
lives in Prince George's County Maryland
he suburb of Washington DC he is selling
real estate he'd be happy for you to
call him he's acting part of the the one
of the problems in Washington is it's
not the white people who are fleeing the
city but the black middle-class they
have left in Durham tens of thousands
since the late 80s and they have moved
in many respects to Prince George's
County just over the DC line in suburban
Maryland where there are tremendous
neighborhoods of homes and schools and
and in fact that County now is fifty
percent african-american in the great
fear for the city as a city resident for
me is to whoever is mayor's got to do
something to help draw people like them
back to the city they are the foundation
for any city and no they need to come
back you paint the picture of the night
that I know our audience saw the Vista
Hotel incident where they arrested
Marion Barry you paint the picture
leading up to that where did you get
that information we got it largely from
from Al Arrington
we got it from some of the the court
records Tom Sherwood was on hand
he was the first reporter at the Vista
yeah I got there was an eerie silence
there was just nothing there there was
not expected pandemonium and there was
just eerie silence and quiet
Mayers car was there the hotel people
were just coming and going as they
normally do the luxury hotel downtown
and then suddenly these two plainclothes
officers come out in the mayor's
security guard is in custody and so I
walked up to I said that's calling by
his name so what's going on
I'd heard that Barry had been arrested
of course I'd played dumb like reporters
try to do in these two police officers
looks like they were about to arrest me
so I backed off and went inside the
hotel we didn't within the next 20
minutes or so we discovered that in fact
the mayor of Washington had been
arrested in this cocaine sting how was
it set up conducted well Mary 1127 yeah
Marion Barry had to be brought up to the
room and he fought it for quite a while
I mean his the great lore was not drugs
but sex Rashida Moore was marionberries
former lover they hadn't seen one
another for a while she kept calling him
up and actually some of the reporting
comes from people who had been in his
office and marionberries office that
afternoon she kept calling him up to
come to the room and he resisted it
because he had a sense too many nosey
Rosie's as he said literally but she
said look I just got some takeout food
from downstairs they're delivering it to
my room why don't you come up here and
have a bite to eat with me and and that
became the reason that Marion Barry
actually came to the room because he
didn't want to do that he kept saying
I'll meet you downstairs came to the
room and then it was a matter of
Rasheeda more actually getting Marion
Barry to smoke some crack and it took a
lot of convincing which I think was one
of the weakest part of the of the
federal government's case because if you
view the videotape it wasn't just Marion
Barry talking on a on a pipe it was the
the amount of time and the amount of
cajoling and the amount of liquor in the
form of cognac that it took to get
Marion Barry to light that crack pipe in
fact
can Monday the defense attorney for
Barry who was who just played a
remarkable role in defending Mary Barry
initially with the gas you know here's
the video tips like Abscam and all those
other cases where you see people who to
the neck and since people stuffing money
in their pockets for Congress in this
case you had the mayor of Washington and
that very clear picture a smoking crack
cocaine and but Ken Mundy was able to
take the jurors and back and say now
look what happened look look at all the
what happened before he reached up and
took the pipe and it was and whether it
was legal and trap was not necessarily
the issue can Monday one of the jurors
to think it was entrapment and they did
and it was some justification it took
too long for Marion Barry to do the
problem do they hit I think there are
two hits and there's even to this day
now there are some people who complained
that the police not only set Marion
Barry up but that also they risk his
life that he could have died from the
head of that cocaine in the end how many
count indictment I think it was 14 or
how many counts was he found guilty in
one and that was a misdemeanor a drug
count involving a woman named Doris
Crenshaw who was a longer player minor
player in a civil rights friend of
marion barry's and i think it was a
political deal struck by the jury to
basically quit on a number of counts and
it was a country on 12
I think the acquittal was on and upon
the busted so right and but again and
then the judge thomas spinvox and the
reagan reagan appointee played a classic
role in stirring the racial fears of the
city the maximum time Barry could get on
that one misdemeanor of cocaine
possession charge was six months and and
the judge made it clear he made a speech
in which he would disparage the jury of
findings in sentence Barry to the six
months so even to this day you could
there are many people who think that
Marion Barry got a raw deal in fact
somebody would the harshest thing I've
heard one person say is that Ted Kennedy
had his problems with Chappaquiddick and
someone died but here he was running for
the Senate and being considered as an
national candidate for president long
afterwards Marion Barry was was
personally involved with drugs and that
the judge treated him so harshly the
fact the judge could have put him on
probation and he would not have had
served one day in jail reaction to this
book well by and large it's it's been
terrific
and gratifying for for me because people
read the book I mean people you know
there are a lot of non-fiction books
about politics that are kind of dry and
this book has enough going on that
people really enjoy it I think that that
the people who we quote and the
information we present has not been
challenged in any serious way by anybody
back to this dedication in memory of my
father Joseph who taught me to love
books and for my mother Zelda who
believes in me and then for Tom Sherwood
for my son Peyton who once innocently
illuminated all the time spent on this
project by telling I'd call her he's not
here he's working on that damn book it
took a long time it took a long time
four years apart from our own
fallibilities and jobs we had to do we
had to put up with the publishing
industry Simon & Schuster it's a big
organization and and all the problems
have put anything together
probably the show - it was just took a
long time but we think we did the right
for the people of the country to
understand more about their nation's
capital do you think it's we wrote it of
course but we think it's the best book
about the nation's capital that tells
you how the Congress has a very bad
system and some of the local politicians
here have made it worse
Harry Jaffe with Washington Toni
magazine Tom Sherwood with local station
WRC this is the book dream city and we
thank you both for joining us thank you